foreign
[Music]
one of the things that's so wonderful
about the violin is it is a very
difficult instrument which means you can
never be too relaxed
[Music]
and you always have to push yourself to
be better every single day
[Music]
well violinist said the Yale School of
Music studying in the master of musical
arts program
[Music]
how can you present an experience that
is accessible to as many people as
possible
so I really wanted to bring history
accessibility music into one space and
to bring it specifically to Sprague
Memorial Hall
In classical music the stage is a little
bit more of a rigid space which is why
for my recital I really wanted to find a
way of bringing this environment of
community and intimacy into one space
I really wanted to experiment with
technology and I wanted to experiment
with storytelling and in a way the whole
recital is one big story about history
foreign
that performance
exactly after that moment is done
[Music]
what I hope to accomplish in this
performance is to bring everything that
I've learned here at Yale into one
performance and to present it to
everyone as a gift from my heart to the
community that has made my life so
special
foreign
[Music]